how about you how you been kill any owls
lately
Kevin Smith
I'll puncher I've been ridiculed so much
for that well because you're you're
you're a criminal against nature that's
what oh man but I'm telling you what I
talked about it on chaotix Kevin and
bean when I went in the morning it
[ __ ] happened I was always an
exclusive we broke that story we did you
guys did and I was my adrenaline was
[ __ ] just running high and [ __ ] the PS
Esther and I told her not to think on
the J and saw a Bob Hope podcast but I
went home and my wife had been sleeping
so I [ __ ] like tell her the [ __ ]
story right and what do you think her
reaction is how the [ __ ] could you hit
that bird I thought was going to think
oh my god you big white hunter you and
then she rolled you over and just made
sweet sweet love to you
right wouldn't you imagine yes like you
tell me what a man if you told me that
story like him then I punched it out and
saved a little dog right I'd be like oh
my god oh that's why I would never tell
you it's like a Tarzan Jane moment like
there you are battling the elements
taking on wild animals that is the most
masculine thing I will ever ever do yeah
and it still wasn't good enough for that
[ __ ] hitting an owl with a semi
deflated pool toy was the most masculine
thing you'll ever do I think about what
you just said that's about Conan moment
that the sound of punching me out right
there okay hear that again there we go
yeah shouldn't do it again Oh put your
punch Edwin Oh
oh my goodness a guy in a hockey jersey
just hit me in the paint
I wish the owl spoke like that man
well for those of you quickly who
haven't heard the story sounds like most
of you have either you heard it on Kevin
and bean or you heard it on I guess you
guys did it with the Jane somebody just
a quick quick quick version of I got a
doc Shinseki I've talked about her a lot
I've got this deck in my house where the
dogs go out and stuff we're gonna have a
yard just like a top tech very exposed
over by Runyon Canyon and I letting the
dogs out two older dogs going to the
back the one little dog strolling around
by the pool and stuff she's cold she
doesn't like to go too far from the
house the more she's got no [ __ ] fur
to speak up so every time I open the
door to let her out in the morning she's
like you're kidding again
yeah like seriously why don't you just
let me piss here so she's out and I
always accompany the dog out because
once when she was very little and I let
her out for one of the first times I
looked up and I saw this low-flying Hawk
and I've never seen something like that
before I was like why is there a bird of
prey around here and then I looked at
the dogs like oh [ __ ]
it was swirling close to her so ever
since then I go out on the deck whenever
she takes leak so I go out on the deck
this morning as per usual and I'm kind
of waking up I waked and baked anyway so
to shop but I'm stretching and whatnot
and I'm kind of looking this way and
then as soon as I turn back like my eyes
are focused and I saw something I don't
know how subscribable it was wasting
laughing at me is that a word wafting
wafting yeah yeah it was just what
really it was gliding but wafting so
cooler it was it was just kind of
descending like this it just it wasn't
doing this [ __ ] like I didn't even think
it was a bird at first I thought it was
a kite and I was like whoo shakey flying
a kite 5:30 in the morning was still
kind of dark and [ __ ] and I was like Ben
Franklin discovered electricity and he
must have had to do it at night this is
all happening in a split second yeah but
anyway by the time I [ __ ] kind of
focus I realized that it's an owl and
he's just kind of like gliding in like
this and not like one of them cute
Harry Potter owls
this one looks [ __ ] fierce yeah I
wish it had a bike it was dark call it
looked like he'd been in some street
fights and [ __ ] there's an urban owl no
more like the crystal meth those
Guardians of Ga'Hoole leal Guardian
something and it was [ __ ] map
looked like he was coming at me like
this Birds [ __ ] nuts man like again
this is all split second and then I
realized he's kind of coming like this
so he's far away but he's coming at my
head but then descending so I'm like oh
my god this bird is heading for my
[ __ ] deck and then I realize you wish
you wish I pull out my [ __ ] camera
I'm like this is gonna be the biggest
[ __ ] youtuber and owl bloomie gonna
beat that gangam style yeah oh my God
look at him suck didn't happen so now I
noticed he was going down down down and
then I realized that he was gonna be
going for my dog Shecky this little
dachshund should be document reduction
she's not face in the owl so it's not
even like she was a warning system of
just like bark bark bird of prey bark
bark or anything like that she was
facing the porch like can we go back in
please not knowing that this thing was
like I'm gonna eat this [ __ ] clueless
dog but I I when I finally register
everything put together man it's like I
had a moment of fight-or-flight and as
you all know I've got the flight
instinct science that's my thing and so
immediately I'm trying to figure out how
to offer this bird head to leave us
alone and [ __ ] but instead of gone all
kind of and the bird pulls out its
camera it's gonna videotape second it's
bird [ __ ] oh this is gonna be awesome on
koo tube I've got like instead of
running which my wife's laying around
she goes why didn't you just grab the
dog and run and I'm like what the [ __ ]
kind of move is that like and where
would I go
cuz the bird was still coming into the
pool
in class and instead it's the pool and
[ __ ] and she would freak cuz I'm holding
her underwater I know how to hold my
breath but she'd be like you're drowning
us you fat pig so I had a split second
man I had talked about there's this pool
toy that was kind of like floating in my
pool had been floating there for months
every month I looked at it and I was
just like hey take this out of [ __ ]
pool nobody really goes in the pool it
just looks so sad look like that stupid
bag in American Beauty and [ __ ] I ran
around look at it's in her life and it
happened in her life man because it was
there for me when I need was an inner
tube so it had an inner life thank you
so much oh we keeping score now is that
how we were so so I basically I'm
standing there now coming this way dog
facing that way I honestly I think I
didn't even think about grabbing the dog
because that dog so low to the ground
that would have required me to bend over
right yeah this didn't the pool toy was
kind of sticking up cuz there's this
round thing that you sit in and it's
padded all around so I guess you know
you could if you're a thinner person you
could twirl it in the water if you're a
person you sink to the bottom and like
this isn't fun at all I I don't know how
I know that but just trust me so it's
been sitting there it's loss of mares
kind of deflated but it's still tall so
that was the only thing within reach and
I swear to you man I grabbed this [ __ ]
this is so [ __ ] strange even when I
think about it now I'm like this is
nothing this cool will ever happen to me
again man nothing nothing I grabbed the
[ __ ] pool toy and I go like this I
totally shut my eyes I would leave that
part out next time you tell the story no
man I totally I was just like turned off
my targeting computer and [ __ ]
I was like do this but BAP and I
connected and I connected man pool toy
to [ __ ] avenging bird hit this
[ __ ] bird like it was a [ __ ]
million one-shot man like give me the
Death Star I'm ready and this bird
glances [ __ ] it goes bang there's to
pull chairs long pull chairs that are on
the deck bang he hits it and go straight
to [ __ ] off when he banked on the chair
that's when the dog was like oh what's
going on and notice like a [ __ ] bird
within range and she was like I'm out
which was amazing cuz she went from
[ __ ] would be prey to sudden predator
right and I was just like this is nuts
like this is [ __ ] nature at its at
its finest Rob and now I'm a part of it
man yeah I entered the food chain with a
pool toy nature intended this thing
takes off into this guy man and I'm
watching it and [ __ ] like it goes up and
it's kind of circles back and I think
it's gonna [ __ ] come back at [ __ ] I'm
ready like [ __ ] Kevin Costner in
Waterworld and [ __ ] just come on I got
the pool toy and was ready to swing
again and I was gonna keep my eyes over
this stuff yeah but this [ __ ]
banked left and went over Runyon and
then was just gone and so it was [ __ ]
so strange and then when I was on the
Kevin and bean show beam was just like
aren't you sad that the dogs never gonna
remember that and I was like what you
son of a [ __ ] you ruined it for you did
we'd always have that I thought like as
the dog the dog would just cut cuddle a
little closer just be like hold you
[ __ ] took a bullet for me man you
punched a now on its [ __ ] face like
cuz I must have looked heroic today if
she just would have looked a little
sooner
yeah like she likes me because I'm
always like treats and [ __ ] rub your
belly and let's go out for a walk and
[ __ ] like that but this would have taken
the cake and whatnot she just seen me be
like [ __ ] your all-time but now she's
just like oh we went out the other
morning that's it I heard something
[Music]
you
[Music]